andrew live chairman
thank you berna good afternoon and
welcome to this
performance governance and audit
committee on thursday the 25th
of february 2021 my name is councillor
jeanette stills
and i am chairman of this committee this
meeting is being held
under new regulations which come into
effect on the 4th of april in response
to the kovit 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all could i please ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone is muted
and your camera is
on this will help to reduce
any background noise and unintentional
disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in
this meeting you are giving your consent
to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function of the
meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak then i
will
invite you at the appropriate time
members
are reminded that apart from
initiating points of order or that you
have to leave the meeting
at the the chat function should not be
used for questions or
any other purpose when speaking
and referring to the agenda papers
please ensure that you reference a page
or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure that
you turn on your microphone
thank you um
now may i ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mr dodson
good afternoon members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
thank you mr dodson mr geller
good afternoon everyone damian geller
lead specialists community
thank you miss scream
are you with us miss green
good afternoon members uh my name's sue
green and i'm the customers community
and casework manager
thank you miss hughes
cheryl hughes programs performance and
governance manager
thank you mr leslie
good afternoon chris leslie director of
resources thank you mr rubens
afternoon greg rubins partner bdo and
head of internal audit
thank you miss sweetly
that's good timing i just managed to get
my audio working so thank you
chair um i'm hannah wheatley specialist
services manager
thank you mr wilson
thank you chair matt wilson countryside
and coast manager
and berna yeah
good afternoon members sorry good
afternoon members burning casey clark to
this afternoon's committee thank you
thank you berna are there any other
officers present
no chairman thank you
before i call on the roll clark uh
call on sorry before i call on the clock
to take the role of the committee
members
can i ask those councillors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please
council morris good afternoon it's
councillor morris here and um i'll just
like to say that i'm considerably
better dressed than councillor jarvis
and i didn't get
the um the memo about dress down
thursday
thank you thank you are there any other
counsellors present
berna can you please carry out the roll
call of committee members to confirm who
is in attendance thank you
thank you chairman members i will call
your names in alphabetical order
please indicate your attendance starting
with counselor jana
good afternoon uh berna good afternoon
members i am present thank you
thank you castle head
afternoon bernard chairman and
colleagues
present thank you casa hall
uh good afternoon everybody yes i'm
president
councillor jarvis yep afternoon burner
chairman members
thank you councillor keys
cancer keys
and thank you uh counselor nun
oh yes honey burner um uh good afternoon
chairman
members i'm here thank you council
shaughnessy
uh yes present burner thank you good
afternoon everyone
thank you casa stamp good afternoon
bernard
chairman and members i'm here too
thank you councillor stills good
afternoon and yes i am present
thank you thank you chairman thank you
may i have the apologies of absence
burner please
thank you chairman we've received
apologies for absence from councillor
helm
thank you item three on the agenda is
the minutes
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 14th
of january 2021 be found on pages 5 to
10
are approved as true and accurate record
i so move if you wish to second that
motion
please unmute your microphone and state
your name now
counselor none seconded thank you
councillor none
if any members wish to raise any matters
of accuracy please
use the hands up function
no okay burner um
can you confirm now berna can you
sorry i've lost myself members do you
wish to agree
the me mem the minutes of this
meeting by ascent agreed
agreed thank you agreed
all right declarations of interest item
4 to disclose the existence of
a nature of any disposable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniar interest relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph
six to eight incluses of the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they are
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
knees
arise throughout the meeting if any
member wishes
uh has an interest to declare can they
please use the hands up function
now councillor chana thank you chairman
my normal one uh i'm also a member of
essex county council i declare
non-binary
in any matter on the agenda relating
to essex or where there could be any
association with essex county council
thank you
thank you councillor chana are there any
other members
no item
five public participation i can advise
that we have not received any
submissions
from members of the public i
have had in accordance with the
regulations
a request to ask a question
from councillor morris i will
come to that when it comes to the
article that he wants to ask the
question on
item six internal internal audit draft
annual plan we move to the agenda item
six found on pages 11-32
in a moment i will call the office of
present to
present this item
mr rubins please can you present your
item
thank you and good afternoon again so um
just very briefly on the plan that's in
front of you just to make a few points
um firstly uh it is um focused around
your key risks
so it is directly linked to those
secondly
has been discussed and agreed with
officers
and the third point to make is of course
we are still going to be in an unusual
year going into this next financial year
so the plan will need to be
flexible and we may need changes through
the year but obviously
as it as previously any changes will be
um presented and agreed with this
committee
and you'll see from the plan it covers a
wide range of reviews we obviously have
the standard finance reviews you'd
expect
and but also some um you know wider
reviews we'd be
focusing on your covid recovery plan for
example looking at
areas like commercialization and
partnerships uh and some of the
uh areas around workforce as well and so
i think um you know fairly wide-ranging
plan
there is obviously the opportunity now
to take comments and questions from
members
and to bring this plan back at the next
meeting uh if you would like any changes
happy to take any comments or questions
thank you councillor jarvis you have
your hand up
chairman if i may um ask a question
of mr rubins uh i note page
15 of the plan appendix 1 page 15
there's a very useful grid
which maps out the likelihood and
consequences of risks
strategic risks in the business um
and i noticed that there's a clump
in the bottom right hand box towards
that box one two three four
obviously with the highest risk uh both
in terms of
impact and uh likelihood one of those
risks
uh i noticed is failure to maintain five
year
supply of housing land uh which of
course we're all aware all council is
aware of the position of the council at
the moment
and it currently falls short of that so
i just wondered with such a
material risk i then noticed that there
was no
current plan to uh to audit
uh in any way the sort of process or
procedures or controls
behind that risk so i just wondered if
you would
be kind enough to comment or offices as
to why it's felt that isn't an area
necessary for audit thank you chairman
yeah i'll start off and it may be
officers want to comment as well i mean
i think
as well as you know looking at the key
risks we have to look at something
that's
auditable and where we think that the
audit is going to add value i i totally
agree this is an area of of priority for
the council but there's a lot of
policy uh issues and wider political
issues
around this area um and i think you know
we're very happy to audit it at a time
where officers feel that there is
something for us to
uh review but maybe it wasn't considered
to be the right timing at the moment but
i'm happy to
pass on to any officers who want to
comment um
mr leslie we would like to make a
comment
yes yeah thank you happy to add to that
absolutely mr rubens is talking about
where value can be added and what we can
gain
um as well from this uh obviously we've
taken care of what we can actually get
and provide information ourselves of
officers to members from that side
and also we have to look ahead in terms
of what we're doing um
clearly there's allocation recently in
the budget for the ldp
as part of that so there is actions
going forward so it's appropriate
actually
what can the auditors add in terms of
the value for money and actually
what value would bring in terms of
ongoing actions and things like that so
it's a consideration about the timing
of the audits as well and what's
currently happened and what information
officers can actually provide to members
uh without internal audits as well
thank you mr dobson did you want to jump
in
thank you chairman i i think mr leslie
actually covered
um most of those those points i think
there are
there are clear reasons some of them
linked to covid
etc as to why the the housing
supply has slipped and the the delivery
over the last few months has been
been slower and pushed plans back um and
we're putting
plans in place as was agreed to council
um this week to address that that issue
um so it's questionable how much value
an
audit would have of that area thank you
thank you uh counselor heard you wanted
to make a
or to ask the question yes thank you
chairman i've i've got three questions
actually um
on on page 15 uh it speaks about
uh failed to plan and deliver a balanced
budget over the median
term well of course on tuesday the
set the budget despite opposition trying
to reduce our income
further but that has been uh
that has been agreed by council
so i'm wondering why that is as high as
it is
as a risk uh also on page
20 chairman failure to deliver
channel shift through lack of customer
engagement
but uh it seems to me that this
council has increased
the amount of public involvement
through the the meetings that we've had
so i think that that channel shift has
has been particularly
good and i hope that that will be
reflected in the review
um a good example is the north west
planning meeting on the 23rd of
september had over 240
visits on the youtube channel
and the other one for mr rubins is on
page 22
which is about corporate governance uh
why are we waiting
until 2022 23
to review uh the the operation
of our newly established committee
structure why are we waiting that long
thank you chairman okay mr rubins would
you like to answer any of those
questions
yeah certainly the first two i think are
are linked together which is um you know
that that part of the plan is just taken
directly from your risk register so
it is the risks as currently seen by the
council now obviously
you may well want to as a council
revisit those risks and the scoring of
those risks but that's
what we've taken and we have to take
that as part of our planning process so
that's why
um that they're presented in that way um
the one around corporate governance
um we can talk to officers about the
timing of that obviously
um it's just really around
prioritization and what
uh we want to do this current year and
what might
they go into next year if members as a
whole feel that that needs to be looked
at earlier rather than later
and you feel that enough time has gone
to embed those new arrangements that
you've put in
uh therefore and they can be subject to
audit and obviously we'd be happy to to
bring that one forward
um thank you mr rims uh councillor heard
we have just completed a governance
audit so
that will be the next agenda meeting
thank you chairman thank you aren't
there any other questions for mr rubins
councillor nan thank you very much chair
yes uh thank you for the report mr
rubins um on page 22 under workforce
management the score seems to be
as stable and consistent currently and
projected
forward at 15.
can you just explain what that means
really
you know what why why are the hr
processes
why have they not been reviewed or is
this a
an annual review we're looking at here
yeah that those their numbers in that
particular page are just the number of
days we would put into our audit so it's
not a score it's the number of days
and given that workforce is a big issue
for the council we'd expect to do some
work on that every year so
that's why we've put that time within
the plan
so sorry just a supplementary so just to
be clear then
through you chair um you're going to be
your team will be spending the
equivalent of 15 days
every year reviewing hr
practice is that
is that a standard is that a standard
um allocation in cancels the size of
moulding
it is for us certainly i mean that's the
kind of time we're talking that when we
when we talk about the 15 days that's to
do a total audit so it includes the
planning the field work the reporting
coming to committee and so on and
dealing with management responses
um it does take a certain amount of time
and they're normally fairly wide-ranging
reviews so
they might be into recruitment um they
might be into sickness management for
example
um workforce planning and i'm afraid yes
it does take a certain amount of time to
do that
at work sorry don't stop me
uh cherry if you feel i'm going on too
far so uh sorry
did you cover all of those things every
year or are you just
looking at individual parts of that list
and it'll be individual parts but
potentially it might be two areas rather
than one
we scope it every year with offices and
determine what the appropriate scope is
for that work
okay okay thank you very much mr room
thank you chair
thank you mr ruby uh does any other
officers want to make any comments on
that because i've got no other hands up
no right thank you for that mr rubins
um there was a lot of work went into
that i know
the recommendation set out within the
report is as
follows recommendation little one that
the committee
considers comments and approves the
internal audit draft plan for 2021-22
at appendix one if any member wishes to
second that motion please
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
okay thank you councillor nana i think
you just got in
um our members happy to take
that recommendation um a succinct
or do you want ricotta vote you agreed
thank you yes agree
thank you great item seven on the agenda
review of corporate risk
we move on to item seven founder on the
agenda pages
33 to 40.
i will call on the officer to present
this item so i call on miss hughes miss
hughes can you
present your report please
yep good afternoon members this report
deals with quarter three risk which
covers
october to december 2020 um
in summary for changes since quarter two
um which is shown in section 3.2 of the
covering report
just with a little bit of explanation
there's one risk that's seen a decrease
in score
this is r23 which is financial resource
and process issues
the reason this score is being reduced
is because all posts have now been
filled with permanent staff
and the result resource risk in finance
is just the same as anywhere else
in the organization as a result the risk
is also recommended for closure
there are no risks that have seen an
increase in score in this period
and clt continue to regularly monitor
and review risks given the current
pandemic measures
at an operational level we now have the
additional balanced scorecard report to
monitor risks that have been removed
from the corporate register
and then things that might need to be
further escalated and should a control
no longer be working
so as an example channel shift figures
were removed as a result of quarter two
reporting
but will continue to be monitored there
thank you
thank you for that chair um can i refer
to the other officers does anybody other
officer want to come in before i open
this up to members
now counselor none i think you had your
hand up first
yes thank you it's um full of hr stuff
uh today isn't it um so thank you very
much
uh cheryl for that um so are you saying
then cheryl that
um we are absolutely fully established
and we have no
vacancies
i have to defer to chris for the
specifics in finance that's the
uh mr leslie sorry chris uh
through through youtube i was just
saying are there any
are there any vacancies or are you fully
absolutely fully established
yes so the risk is around the the
finance team i think that was originally
step so in terms of the finance team
there are no vacancies they're all feel
we've got permanent people in post
right well that's really that's really
good chair um
thank you very much thank you miss
uh councillor jarvis you've got your
hand up
yes thanks chairman i'll be brief it's
really just an observation
and i will be making a comment on the
next points on the agenda as well in
relation to this
but it's just an observation regarding
the five-year land supply point
so if i go to page 37 our r7
i think the risk title is and we see
there
in the comment box that a master
spreadsheet for housing
is being prepared and this will make
monitoring
easier to analyze the stats more quickly
and clearly just make sort of the
observation really i think this comes
back
to my original point regarding perhaps
somebody looking at controls and looking
at the risk
um you know i i i think my point is
really that
we shouldn't wait to find out that we
don't have a five-year land supply
quite a long time ahead of that we
should be monitoring
uh so that we're aware of it we can see
it coming and we're doing
everything we can perhaps to mitigate um
falling below the five year so i'll just
make that observation but i'd
like to make a further comment on agenda
item 8
to wrap up my land supply commentary
thank you chairman
thank you mr dobson do you want to reply
to that before i go to miss
chana
yes thank you chairman um yes we do
monitor
um throughout um the the year
we actually do a formal response to
government um
once a year on that which is in the the
third quarter
to which this this report um refers
and it was linked to some of the the
issues that were raised just ahead of
that
um response being done that did lead to
the
the five-year housing land supply issues
that we raised
but we do monitor it and because of some
of the
the various issues that had happened
through the year that was why the risk
is at the level
um that it's at thank you thank you
councillor channel you have your hand up
uh thank you madam chairman um i'm
referring to pence i've just dropped
something i was trying to read from
okay um um
regarding the appendix our thief failure
to target
services influence partners effectively
to support identified housing needs of
increasing population
it says um and it's a risk overall
rating risk of 12
discussions on the purchase of
development land is progressing well
and appears to be on target
can um someone refresh me what exactly
is the target period
and when um will perhaps members be
aware of
what purchase of development land um
avenues may be being
looked at or being worked on
thank you councillor channel i think mr
dobson
is ready to come in on that one yes
thank you
chairman yes um members will remember we
did bring a confidential paper
to council to raise um some of the
proposals and opportunities for
purchasing land to support
housing delivery um particularly around
affordable housing
we are progressing some of those
discussions um but they are commercially
confidential
at present so um i can't share um
further details in this meeting itself
but happy to outside of this meeting
thank you thank you mr madam chairman
thank you
uh councillor chandler can you take your
hand now please thank you
sorry don't have much luck with muting
and hands these days thank you
the recommendations are set out within
the report as below so recommendations
little one is the members review the
corporate risk register in appendix one
and
provide comment and feedback for
consideration
a little little too that the members are
assured through this review that the
corporate risk
is being managed effectively and little
through that members
challenge risks where the committee
feels that the council's corporate goals
may not be achieved
if any member wishes to second that
motion please unmute your microphone and
state your name now
councillor joe alice thank you
councillor jarvis
are you happy to take the vote
by a saint
agreed great thank you agreed
item a review of the corporate
performance quarter three we move to
item eight on the agenda found on pages
41-62
i will call on the officer present to
present
their report mrs miss hughes is back to
you again
thank you um so again members this is
the performance report
for quarter three which covers october
to december 2020
and it's provided for committee review
and to track delivery of the corporate
plan
as highlighted in the previous reporting
throughout the year there are measures
that aren't performing according to
where they thought we would be
and this is largely down to the impact
of covid and how we have had to deliver
services differently or where resources
have been diverted
you'll see in section 3.3 of the
covering report a summary
table that highlights each of the three
themes the number of measures that are
on track or otherwise and section 3.4
then highlights the specific measures
that have areas of concern
at a summary level um in the community
theme
overall performance delivery is broadly
on track but there are a few
outcomes impacted by covid and also
impacted where there's a vacancy
due to be filled but there's no
actionable concerns
in place overall performance delivery is
mainly on track
and there are a few outcomes and
activities impacted by covid
and but there's no actionable concerns
and for prosperity
performance delivery is broadly on track
um and there's some
outcomes and activities impacted by
covid uh
one outcome specifically which shows
initial concern for
delivery is the delivery of strategic
employment
sites in accordance with the local
delivery plan
the appendix report found on pages 45 to
62
is the full set of data and supporting
plans
that help us to monitor and track that
delivery you will see in
this there are specific indicators like
the
annual better care fund grants which
haven't been able to be spent
because home visits couldn't go ahead or
in-person online assistance which was
due to take place at the office
but hasn't happened because the office
has moved to appointment only
and they're amongst the specific
detailed indicators that have been
impacted by covet
however there is some new activity
that's taken place
that wasn't originally listed on the
corporate plan activity
has included things like an increase in
channel shift
as a result of how we've changed our
operations um a move to virtual fitness
campaigns
and direct engagement with those in
isolation risk groups for covid which
far surpasses the original target of
people that we expected to
reach in isolation programmes and
volunteering activity
um used that was originally for open
spaces
has been redeployed to the covid
response
um this illustrates that although we
said we would deliver
uh how we said we'd deliver some of the
objectives has changed
there is additional activity that
underpins some of these wider corporate
goals
there's a wider review of the corporate
plan objectives being undertaken at the
moment by the strategy team
and we're of course feeding into this to
ensure appropriate performance reporting
will be taken forward as part of this
the intention is that quarter one report
will then come to september's pga to
track the revised corporate plan as part
of this
thank you members thank you miss hughes
uh councillor jarvis you've got your
hand up
uh thank you chairman well this is going
to be the last point you pleased to hear
that i'm going to mention on the
five-year land supply but if you go to
page 54
block g or diagrams g illustration
g which is on the housing land supply
now
i know the this is a report which is uh
dated
there's a time frame so this is a report
that was produced on date is on data
which is before we've slipped uh below
the five-year land supply
so if you look at g you'd look at that
and think well that doesn't look like
there's a problem
and that's because obviously it's from a
time period i'm sure officers
will clarify which is before we've
fallen below the five-year land supply
but my point is really this is that um
which ties are hopefully through
the points i've made on the five-year
land supply at the various points during
the meeting here is
that i'd like to see a system whereby
i can see a problem before i've got it
where i can see that i've got an
appetite
say for example on the five-year land
supply perhaps i'd be interested to know
i would be interested to know
if it was below 4.8 if it was likely to
fall below
i'd like to see a more predictive tool
so i can see where i'm going to have a
problem
and so i can then see ask officers what
are they doing to try and avoid
the problem because what i see here is
something that
is just telling me i might actually have
a problem if i already know i've got a
problem
so it's a bit late that's my point
really about sorry to harp on
today about a specific issue but it's
the tool which i think is missing
it's not so much the five-year land
supply issue i've made these points
it's the mechanism we should be having i
feel as a committee
we should be presented with some form of
tool
that tells us where things could go
wrong
and we might set appetites uh appetite
levels
which if they're triggered come to us so
i'd like to have seen the five-year land
supply issue come to me
at least six months ago when it would
have been amberated and it would have
said
we might have a problem here and we
could have looked to see what we could
do about it
and that really chairman is my point
thank you very much i would like to hear
from officers on that point thank you
thank you
councillor jarvis is there any officer
that would like to come back
uh mr dobson yes
thank you chairman um the the
performance reports are
in in essence backward looking they they
show the performance as it has happened
and
and report to it a quarter in arrears
generally as as we do um
the point of having the risk assessments
alongside of that
and bringing both to this this committee
are that it's highlighted
within the risks and that they can be
read together
that if there is a a risk and an
increase in risk
through the monitoring that we're doing
alongside that performance report
then we do raise risks when when there
are risks
to performance whether that could be
slightly more sophisticated because the
risks come at a corporate level
and with that we can look at that in a
bit more detail
and see if we can add some further
intelligence
into this we also have the the balanced
scorecard reporting
and that we bring through that
highlights those um
but with those um
with those comments i i also take on
board that we can take and take a look
at this
and see if there's anything that we can
do thank you
thank you mr dobson councillor none you
have your hand up
yes well uh if you don't mind indulging
me a moment uh chairman i think that
given the
the pressures of covid that have been
mentioned
uh but other things that the staff have
had to be dealing with like
flooding for example and the elections
and everything else that they're
they're dealing with at the moment um
you know i'm amazed that the performance
levels are as on track as they are
and um you know i think this is a
testament to
the management of the district council
and their staff
um that they are doing so well and i
just think we need to put that on record
and you know as we move towards more
positive times
hopefully um with with the covered
controls
you know we can start looking at
different areas of performance but
i think given the emergency this is very
good thank you councillor nan nunn
councillor hull do you you have your
hand up
yes yes thank you i might have just
missed this but
um it said that um a lot of the money
put by
for the community like um keeping fit
and
healthy and things like that the the
money that it wasn't used
and it's been has that all been put into
the
covid fund or is there still some there
for
for groups that need it thank you
do you want to answer that sure what
shall i go to mr leslie
so it wasn't specific to money it was
officer time
so um the opposite time has been
diverted um from what they originally
thought they were doing to
the covid responses so is this
still a pot for the community to
if they need something
to go to mr something the answer to that
would you like mr leslie to come in yeah
we can do is the
the actual indicator um so the data's
showing that the officer time's been
diverted so it's not necessarily that
there's a pot available
and because the officer time has been
spent elsewhere
i think that's the point that i was
trying to make all right
it's just that i'm from another
committee i heard that there was
you know to help keep people keep fit
and for booster tea and things like that
that there is funding still available
from the council is that correct or have
i got it
wrong chris have you got any uh oh
i've got um miss green has said that she
can
help to assist on that answer i love you
thank you
thank you chairman um yes that we do
have a pot of money through our health
and wellbeing funding that we get
from essex county council and yes there
is funding available there to support
community activity to improve health and
well-being
um it's something we're currently
looking at some of that money is
being distributed for our health and
well-being partnership board but equally
there is some that is available
for community activity and we're
currently looking at how we can
support communities to get that money
out so absolutely members
oh lovely is do you know how much there
is that oh sorry
so can i come in again go on counselor
how i'll let you come in again
sorry do you know what sort of funding
there is available
how much or
um not right at this moment but i
believe we get something in the region
of about
15 to 18 000 pounds a year from essex
county council which is available to
support a whole range of activities
um but the exact amount is available
right this moment i couldn't tell you
but i certainly know there is some that
is available
would it help can you cancel the whole
will it help if
miss green goes away and looks at that
and then emails all the time
fantastic that's lovely thank you very
much thank you
thank you members are there any other
questions
for me too
counselor hulk could you take your hand
down please
know they they've moved them around
so members the recommendations that are
within the report are as follows
recommendations one the members review
the information set out in this report
and appendix one with priority focus
given to the strategic outline
outcome level performance and little to
the members confirm they are assured
through this review that corporate
performance is being managed effectively
if any member wishes to second that
promotion please and
mute your microphone and state your name
now
thanks lou jarvis thank you councillor
jarvis
our members happy to agree this by a
saint
the great thank you agreed
moving on to item nine on the agenda
which is the health and safety update
quarter three
we move to agenda item 9 found on pages
63-68 i will call on mr wilson to
present this report
thank you chair um so this is the
quarter 3 report
for health and safety as you can see
it's relatively short
um two incidents reported in this
quarter
one a slip on an access ramp where
remedial works were carried out
and the second one uh involving the
maroon firing
uh down at burnham on couch
the uh there were two incidents of
unacceptable behavior both in the waste
uh and have been dealt with enlarged
procedures and point three point three
is regarding our communications with the
inspector from the health and safety
executive there were a number of actions
that they'd
asked us to take all of which were done
in good time and although some of the
dates may appear to have slipped we had
communication in between times
with the inspector and they are fully
satisfied
our last communication with them was
mid-november and we've had nothing since
thank you mr wilson does any members
have any questions for mr wilson
councillor morris you have asked if you
can ask a question
and i will give you permission to do
that
thank you very much uh madam chairman
and i'd just like to say how radiant you
are looking today
um i apologize to councillor jarvis for
my earlier quip
and uh decided to uh you know dress down
for you so councillor jarvis you're no
longer the most daddy man in the room
um thank you um mr wilson i was just
wondering we did speak earlier today and
i thank you for getting back to me so
promptly
i was just wondering um the question
that i was going to ask was that
i've been informed that there are
certain members of staff
that haven't got first aid certification
um
could you just repeat your answer again
just uh there may be a member of the
public watching that um would need to
know
the answer to that question and um
you're a lot more uh
better at giving it than i am certainly
thank you council morris
um yes so i believe the crew is
particularly around our frontline staff
parks team
uh maintenance um so a number of staff
do have certificates
that are due to end they were due to end
at the beginning of february this year
uh however we've been in communication
with the trainers it's not been possible
to undertake the training due to covid
so face-to-face training is not taking
place
uh and the trainer has been invite has
advised us that the
um not only is there normally a month's
extension on the certification anyway
but actually that extension has gone
through the 31st of march
um we're in contact through the hr team
we're in contact with the trainer
uh and we'll see additional guidance it
looks likely
um that a further extension may be
granted um
purely because rule of six will mean
that we can't actually undertake any
face-to-face training probably until the
17th of may um
if we're able to do it before then we
will but
suffice to say and please be reassured
that where we can
undertake the training we are doing it
we had 13 staff undertake first aid
training in october
in that brief window where we're able to
um quick supplementary please chair i
will allow you a supplementary on a
little
other people do that it's because i gave
you the compliment at the start isn't it
mr wilton um i was just gonna say that
uh the rule of six probably wouldn't
apply
because i do believe there would be an
exemption to that as far as because it
would be uh a work related activity so
that
may not apply and um any new members of
staff that have joined
uh does that mean that they haven't got
any first day training
uh no we we put new members of staff
through in october
so we had a number of courses run so
some of those were within the
community protection team some were in
parks and we had a high res ranger
whose certificate actually lapsed so
needed to renew the course as well
great thank you so much i'm very
reassured knowing that if i fall over in
the promenade
one of the uh parks guys can kiss me
back to life thank you
thank you chair thank you councillor
maurice councillor hall you have a
question
no i just had a comment really and we do
a lot of first
aid training and if and we do it outside
in a barn
and you're quite welcome to bring any of
your workforce and trainers
and because it worked quite well um we
tried to get all our children first aid
trained and
assistants and so that's if you're
welcome you're welcome to come and use
the barn
anytime thank you thank you councillor
hull
is there any other questions no
i will remove i will move to
recommendations the recommendations
are letter one to note the accident and
incident statistics and
little two to note the health and safety
activity for quarter three
any member who wishes to second that
motion please unmute your microphone and
state your name now
counselor none seconded thank you
councillor nunn
are you happy to agree that by a cent
councillors
you praise me agreed thank you
councillor channel were you waving at me
or just agreeing
rather than playing around with my mute
button i put my hand up
that's all right that's lovely thank you
councillor chana
item 10 any other items on the bus
of items or any other items of business
that the chairman decides are urgent
there are none
so item 11 i will close this meeting
at 14 45. thank you all for attending
the meeting is now closed you are not
advised
not to enter into any further
discussions on this forum and please
leave the meeting promptly thank you
thank you very much